[Music]
hey how's it going fellow comrades
that's right today we're doing another
vlog we're going to Yokohama which is
about an hour away from Tokyo we never
been it looked cool but it's raining
it's supposed to clear up pretty soon
but most importantly we are matching
squad
[Music]
we're here and we're heading over
somewhere somewhere behind me best blog
so here's a bow
look how cute they all have little hats
[Music]
we really picked the busiest day to come
here it's just so many people that's the
thing about Japan you just have to be
ready that huge amount of crowds
everywhere can you ride this let's go up
music playing oh we're going my legs are
too long this is so good
watch out my oh it does Pikachu
let's go - Pikachu in three years
marzia you just love time I guess we're
going up to surf when you're on the
wrong ride clearly I'm joking now I did
nine and I didn't I - thirty in the ice
world that's insanely cool we're going
in
my god it's so cold I'm so cold
[Music]
oh I don't know what I was expecting
with -30 but Jesus Christ my nostrils
are freezing up how are you not dying
that's kind of cool can i oh my god that
was so refreshing now we're out in the
heart again it feels nice now someone
died that was my joke wait we're going
on the family banana store over there
whenever we go to Brighton there's the
pier and they have a bunch of rides on
it and I hope we always see a lot of
Asian people going on the rides and I'm
always like why why would they come here
to go on and on like these shitty rides
and here we are in Japan all the rights
are really fun where they last like 10
seconds yeah so the haunted houses shut
down but it's called dr. Edgar virtual
reality vehicle a thousand meter drop so
I'm doing this one
[Music]
Hey
whoa when this is scourge they got zero
points oh let's go we got to get the
high score you have to scream as loud as
possible on the last jump and there's a
high score we have to win we just came
for the wheel but this is so awesome
they have so many things okay we're
going to die
[Music]
233 I was not good enough people
laughing okay so this haunted house is
open Jesus Christ oh my god Japan I
don't know if I want to do that well we
get to pick how scary
we take maximum oh this is creepy no oh
my god there's something there I'm
protecting you much why is it so quiet
what if there's something in the cage
with us Jase I wasn't even that scary
wasn't even spirit
are you kidding me
[Applause]
I won you this one so good we get you
what did you do
Pikachu what did you do
[Music]
we're going to the cup noodle Museum now
which you can make your own ramen with
your own plate with your own flavor
apparently cup noodle was invented in
Yokohama that's why they have this giant
museum here but they have them
everywhere look how much ramen it's
amazing
[Music]
yummy so this is the first ramen ever
chiquinha ramen and then it just kept
growing
so now we get to draw
[Applause]
alright let's see them yours looks so
good and then yeah does it say ramen
then we have my I wanted it to look
spicy like I think so
and this is how I want to look when I
eat it there you go
very nice thank you
oh it's hot it's really hot I'm so
hungry now
okay so last thing that we planned on
today's trip was to go to Chinatown and
here we are
it looks amazing so pretty so apparently
the Chinatown is really famous here that
guy straight up looked like he murdered
people for his sushi business I could be
wrong I'm sorry if I'm wrong might say
don't look what's up with the hell
Phillip I'd really like the Hat that
you're happy I went and bought it on
represent cash credit path and set
reminder my best purchases I think all
the comments should burn as well what do
you think browser
we got a cute picture the waiter was so
sweet he kept asking if we wanted to
take pictures and we were like sure oh
god the food was so good I love Yokohama
oh my God look at that so pretty
[Music]
all right well here we are
we went back just to see the wheel when
it's lit up we had a great time great
blog and thanks for coming along thank
you for leaving like and bind the March
appreciate you for real it really helps
out I really really appreciate it thanks
for all this support so far whoa
[Music]
you